to speak about histiocytic neoplasms, my financial disclosures.
So histiocytic neoplasms, including Langerhans, Erdheim-Chester, Rosler-Dorfman,
are a rare group of diseases where having 15 patients makes me somehow a quote-unquote expert.
It's a heterogeneous group of disease characterized by infiltration of organs by these clonal myeloid cells
where the MAP kinase pathway mutation arises in a precursor cell.
And depending on which stage of this differentiation, the precursor cells are affected,
you can get multisystem disease or low-risk disease or a single-system disease.
And as you can see in the figure here, this is a representative of a patient with Langerhans
where there's skin involvement, lung involvement, bone involvement, and also CNS involvement.
And the NCCN guideline has a really nice table of the characteristic features of histiocytic neoplasms.
Some of the buzzwords you might hear are, for Erdheim-Chester, you might hear osteosclerosis of the bone
or hairy kidney or periaortic infiltration.
And for Langerhans, you might see lung involvement and bone involvement, characteristically.
And for Rosler-Dorfman, you might see some lymphadenopathy.
We've learned recently that the MAP kinase pathway mutation really plays a critical role
in the pathogenesis of these Langerhans and Erdheim-Chester where about half of the patients
have the BRAV BRAF mutation and another about 30% of the people have the MAP to kinase pathway mutation.
Rosler-Dorfman disease is a little bit different from the MAP kinase pathway mutation.
The other two, they don't have a lot of the BRAV mutation, but has the MAP to K1 mutations in about 45% of the case
and the NRAS mutation in 45% of the cases.
So then naturally, if you have a BRAV mutation, you want to start targeting it to see if that will be effective.
Prior to these targeted therapies, people were treated with cytotoxic chemotherapy, including cladribine.
And this study in 2017 was called a VE basket study, included patients with various non-melanoma cancers
who have BRAV BRAF mutations.
And 26 patients of these had histiocytic neoplasms and were treated with bimerafenib, 960 mg twice daily,
and with a remarkable overall response rate of 61.5%.
And this study was done in 2017.
and a two-year progression-free survival of 86%.
So this study led to the approval of imirafinib in VRAF BRAF mutated histiocytic neoplasms.
Now, but half of the patients do not harbor the VRAF mutation, so then you're wondering
if you can get the MEK inhibitor to work.
So this study included 18 patients with ECD, LCH, and RDD, and these patients were treated
with covimetinib, 16 milligrams, and another remarkable overall response rate.
And by the way, these patients had various types of mutations, as you can see in the
figures below, but the overall response rate was about 89% by PET response criteria.
All responses were durable.
And there were no prior resistance later on.
So this study led to the FDA approval of covimetinib in histiocytic neoplasm patients, regardless
of their mutation status.
And then we haven't had anything really groundbreaking for a long time.
There were various VRAF inhibitors and MEK inhibitors that we, you know, we saw that
they work.
That's a no-brainer.
But then recently, there was a study in RDD, where patients were treated with lenalidomide,
and the thought is that the anti-inflammatory properties of lenalidomide might help in patients
with RDD.
So 23 patients were treated with lenalidomide and dexamethasone, and at a medium follow-up
of 26 months, the two-year overall survival was 100%, and 17 of the 23 patients had response.
So this is also on the NCCN guidelines.
And patients who have failed other therapies as an option.
So there are still several areas of unmet need, and it's just like neoplasms.
And one thing is, are we ever going to achieve cure?
Because we've observed that patients who are on targeted therapy, who go off on these
therapies, inevitably relapse in 50% to 80% of the cases.
Although they do respond to re-treatment.
And another sort of devastating side effect or clinical presentation of these histoacetic
neoplasms is neurodegeneration.
And this occurs mostly in patients with LCH and ECD.
And clinical manifestations include cerebellar ataxia, dysarthria, cognitive impairment,
and behavior abnormalities.
It's thought to be.
So there's a lot to be said about neurodegeneration from these BRAF-mutated cells that are predominantly
in the microglia and the cerebellar area that leads to these neurodegeneration.
And unfortunately, these targeted therapies and cytotoxic chemotherapy might slow down
the progression.
However, it is thought to be irreversible.
So these are my summary slides and references.
And thank you.